a college student recently asked me
whether students should invest in
Bitcoin I said I don't give investment
advice but I cautioned her be careful
what you mean by invest you see crypto
currencies or coins aren't like stocks
that give you rights to a company with
most coins all you own is the right to
transfer it to someone else
she said that sounds like traditional
currencies so why does Bitcoin fluctuate
in value so much with traditional
currencies when people want to do more
transactions or save more the amount of
the currency grows if governments are
doing their job so the value stays about
the same not so at crypto currencies
their supply is driven by software which
generally creates new coin a fixed pace
regardless of the demand for the coin so
whenever people want more whether for
transactions or to speculate for future
values or just because they're
enthusiastic about coin the value grows
when people want less the value drops
it's all about demand so with
cryptocurrencies know what you own do
you think cryptocurrencies are a good
investment let us know your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI